The deadline to vote
Yep.
is around the corner,
and I know this is a major cause of yours,
and I think it's something that
everybody's concerned about
right now, which is
the number of people that
will decide this election,
decided the last election
was so razor thin that
everyone needs to understand
how important their vote is.
It's crucial.
Oh, and you know, it amazes
me to hear people say,
"Well, I didn't vote 'cause
I didn't think it mattered."
And, as you mentioned, this last election,
in some of the swing states,
the margin of difference
was five votes per precinct.
And that wasn't just unique
to this past election.
I mean, I have been campaigning
in midterm elections
and in the last several elections,
and I've looked at the statistics,
and every time you look
at the margin of victory,
because we have such a
low voting percentage
in this country,
that for every election, at every level,
we're talking about one,
two, five, 10, 50 votes
that determine who your mayor is,
who your governor is,
who your council member is.
So, every vote absolutely matters,
and people just take this for granted.
And then when it doesn't turn
out the way they had hoped,
they're shocked and upset.
But this is a democracy,
and yes, sometimes it's frustrating,
and sometimes it can be alienating.
I get that,
but I've also traveled the world,
and I've seen other forms of government,
and I wouldn't trade our democracy
for anything in the world,
but in order for it to work,
we need active, engaged
and informed citizens
who are ready to do the
one, pretty simple thing,
which is vote.
And you can mail it in. (chuckles)
Yep.
You can stand in line
if you want.
You can vote early,
you can do it all ways,
yes, we could have more ways to vote.
It could be easier,
and hopefully with the right leadership,
we'll get voting requirements
that will be easier.
But right now, it's pretty easy.
(laughs)
Yeah.
It takes some planning,
and people can get the
information they need,
but we just can't afford for
people to take the attitude
that voting doesn't count.
It absolutely does.